hey guys
e.t is taking over my show it's magical
chloe i love you so much
this was a prank call this was a prank
call and i'm on
entertainment tonight and this is
wild that you were so nice to me this
morning
here's chris who runs this office
absolutely the most efficient greatest
business partner i've ever had how can
i'll just say uh-huh
no honey that's not because that's not
the way that is not the way it works
around this house i'm guaranteeing it
pretend it does
for five minutes okay hi everybody in
entertainment tonight i'm bruce jenner
and i'm kris jenner come on in and we'll
show you around
well like all good little jenners we eat
our wheaties in the breakfast room
you know they're gonna bring sweet pea
over kendall are you excited
we're in kendall and kylie's dollhouse
welcome to their little villa that we
have here at the jenner house huh girls
huh this is where we spend a lot of time
this is like a little oh there goes
kendall upstairs so you'll see what's up
at the top
be careful girls go out on the top and
show them where you are upstairs okay
we spend a lot of time out here go on
out kylie
the camera there you go say hi everybody
hi everybody
[Music]
and ladies this week please
kim's new cover girl shots i have a huge
surprise for you
this week you're on the cover of okay
magazine no way are you serious yes
no way i don't want to lose my job see
you later honey you're going to be late
get home and get into bed
it's past your bedtime let me see what
it says
um how do i stay thin but keep my sexy
car for your boyfriend's
what are your wedding and baby plans you
didn't tell me about that
i am you're grounded get home and go to
bed it's past your bedtime
dead winners of dancing with the
this is stars news
so this is the desk that i'm going to
come out to
every single morning and this is where
the guest and the co-host is going to
sit and
this is my chair and i'm actually seeing
it and i'm going to sit in it for the
first time
with you what right honor oh hi welcome
to chris
hi thank you chris so okay so we're
going to come out here
and then we're going to go from that
into like pop
culture news topics news of the day
what happened last night doesn't that
sound like fun it's incredible so
fun fashion fabulous
fitness fantastic like
a whole big party all summer long here
we go
jungle booger
oh no
here we go here we go smiling with that
camera
and action marshall you made a brave
step today
remember what shakespeare wrote virtue
is bold
and goodness never fearful let's do this
lead the way
these girls are really smart and i think
that one thing that's so attractive
about them is
you know their work ethic because my job
at the beginning of all of this
was to take 15 minutes and turn it into
30. you know and
you're the momager well yeah and and i
and i do i manage their careers
i trademarked that name by the way of
course
of course she does there'll be a line of
something mommager
ice pops you know this isn't an accident
it just doesn't happen
you know overnight you wake up one day
and you know it's all of this
it takes a lot of work and dedication to
get to
a level like this and one thing i will
say for everybody you know is that we
appreciate it
so much
well i think that my proudest job is
being a mom
you know as long as my kids are okay and
everybody's you know
doing fine and and you know it's just um
uh worry about their well-being and
their happiness that's number one
can we just say that we are 10 feet from
baby north
and ken and kanye that's pretty cool
it's fun well they're my roommates and i
live down the hall
i feel the happiest when i have family
around
i know you guys uh love your prank calls
in your family
it's genius and fun to watch and is
there any shot
silly that i can convince you to do a
little prank call like with
with one of your kids right now if we
could get on the foot could we do that
who's awake
we could try chloe
oh this is gonna be good
hello listen i have a really quick
question
so i got a call from um the playboy
company
you know the people that took over after
have passed away
oh yeah i would love to do playboy no no
no
they asked they asked me to do playboy
like
naked you're gonna be naked well they
said that i didn't have to show anything
okay they said the same thing to kim
right so is that a no
listen it's your life i support you you
support
us but if you're not going to show
anything then there's no reason to be
naked in photos and you could wear
underwear
and a bra or whatever yeah that's a good
idea
like kim was vagina like i am just not
that stupid like i know
if you take a picture with your vagina
out they're probably gonna use it
yeah you're right okay well i'll cover
my vagina
i mean is this a real thing though i
i don't know they're telling me it is i
mean
how do you feel in your life at the
beautiful old beautiful young age of
you know later 50s
i'm giving you see how i did that just
take off a few years
well i feel like photoshop there's
always photoshop
yeah of course but you're so gorgeous
you don't really need much and you're
like the hottest mom i've ever seen
chloe i love you so much
this was a prank call this was a prank
call and i'm on entertainment tonight
and this is wild that you were so nice
to me this morning
that was amazing so supportive of us
so why not oh chloe
that was really sweet
say say hi to cameron hey chloe
hi everybody
[Laughter]
well played chloe one good one i'm
almost blushing